oh
bro who voted for this all right cheers
let's get it
[Music]
it is week five punishment time and this
week there were three losers so flemlo
lou and myself were those losers the
only people that really showed up for me
was derek henry and the cowboys defense
i picked my whole bengals receiving
corps and joe burrow that was your
problem joe went off jamar went off but
tyler boyd and uh and t they let me down
this week so for our punishment we have
to eat the entire banana
with the peel i googled it they said
that eating the banana peel is really
healthy the antibiotics the fiber this
is the most nutrient dense part of the
banana it's also the worst tasting so
here we go
[Music]
oh my god it tastes like rubber i don't
like that this is trash it is awful yeah
damn
oh
i'm halfway done how are you guys doing
you're holding in there
ah really
man you feel like i'm eating dirt
goodness gracious i don't know if i'm
ever gonna eat a banana again did you
guys eat the stem too
i think lou started with this dude
people voted for this they're they're
sick almost there
bro this is the worst part bro i swear
just keep grinding
that bite
we're done that was terrible we'll see
you guys wednesday interested to see
what the next punishment's gonna be
because it's not gonna be me i'm gonna
come out there like tyson's fury don't
get used to seeing me here
[Music]